I was a mosquito once,
carried by the breeze
in the Grizedale forest
in the north of England.
As I drifted between the trees,
surrounded by the chatter of the forest,
swirling waves of pink
and purple engulfed me.
Plumes of carbon dioxide
and oxygen as the forest breathed,
mesmerized by the beauty
never before glimpsed by human eyes.
And I was in awe.
Then I was eaten by a dragonfly.
I became a dragonfly
and discovered a magical world
in which the entire forest unfurled
like a film in slow motion,
yet faster than your iPhone
camera could capture it.
Through my dragonfly eyes,
I took in my surroundings
with pretty much
a full spectrum of light,
unlike my human self
had ever been able to perceive.
These forays into becoming
something other than human
came about as part
of our experiential art piece
called “In the Eyes of the Animal,”
which I developed with my creative
partners, Barney and Robin,
alongside the members of our art
collective, Marshmallow Laser Feast.
Our aim was to translate the sensory
perception of different species --
a mosquito, a dragonfly,
a frog and an owl --
so we can more deeply understand
how they see, hear and feel.
It was for us a step into umwelt,
a concept coined by the pioneering
biologist Jakob Von Uexküll
to describe the unique
sensory world of an organism.
Human notion of reality
is just one among millions.
Each species has its own extraordinary
and unknowable experience of reality
based on the unique ways their senses
translate the world around them.
In essence,
your and my umwelt fundamentally differs
from the umwelt
of a mosquito or a dragonfly.
Marcel Proust once wrote
"The only true voyage of discovery
is to behold the universe
through the eyes of another."
Our voyage of discovery
into animal kingdom
led us to plant kingdom
and eventually to trees where miracles
appear in every level of magnification.
All we need to do is to look closely.
In 2016,
we found ourselves standing
in front of a giant sequoia tree
in Sequoia National Park in California.
These giant trees are portals
through which you leave
your human self-importance behind
and embody something
much larger, much stranger,
much more than human.
All I could think of was,
"What is it like to be a tree?"
What is it like to be one of the largest
organisms that has ever existed?
One that has endured
more than 2,500 years?
How does it feel to host
a vast web of relationships
that anchor an entire ecosystem?
Now step with me into this giant
as we peer through the bark,
the vascular system
of the tree reveals itself.
Infinitely complex
patterns and relationships,
connect all forms of life
into a tapestry of interdependence.
Carbon and water,
more than 1,000 liters of water, in fact,
flow freely through the phloem
and xylem tubes carry it along.
We ascend to the canopy.
Among the neon green moss
and the lichen-covered branches,
we shrink in size
and sit upon a pine needle.
A photon of light hits the surface,
water turns into oxygen
and the life we know it
materializes in front of us.
This extraordinary journey of water
inspired us to create our multi-sensory,
mixed-reality installation
called “Tree Hugger.”
With a team of scientists,
programmers, engineers,
LiDAR scanners and scent makers,
we immerse ourselves
in the inner workings of a sequoia
to render visible what was otherwise
invisible to human eyes.
Mileece L'Anson, composer and a musician,
recorded human and plant
bioelectrical signals
to give us a symphony,
a soundscape composed
in collaboration with the flora.
In fact, that's what
you've been hearing all along.
Participants wore a haptic vest
to feel these vibrations
as if their own heartbeat,
bringing us a step closer,
imagining what it is like to be a tree.
When we contemplate the relationship
between our breathing cells
and the breathing planet,
we encounter this great question.
Where does my body end
and where does the world begin?
As you ask yourself this question,
I'd like you to pay attention
to your breath.
Inhale slowly.
And exhale.
Feel your tree-like lungs filling
and emptying with a rhythmic flow of air.
Oxygenated blood reaches your heart.
Your heart pumps
like a murmuration of birds,
feeding rivers from the center outwards
to touch every cell in your body.
Under your skin, you realize
you are much like a forest ecosystem.
In modern industrial societies,
we tend to limit our being to our body.
Shaped by the confines of your skin,
your body is you
and that’s where your you ends.
Yet, when we trace our outbreath,
the boundary between inside and outside,
between self and other, blurs.
The air we breathe transcends boundaries,
sustaining life as it flows
between all beings.
We take anywhere from 17,000
to 30,000 breaths a day.
A third of those breaths
coming from the forests
and the rest coming from the oceans.
This puts us in an intimate
relationship with the trees
thousands of times a day.
You might think you've never met
a giant sequoia before, but in fact,
you've been enmeshed
and entangled with one
every moment you've been alive.
In other words,
we are as much trees as trees are us.
Our multisensory,
mixed-reality installation
called “We Live in an Ocean of Air”
started with this realization.
By translating the umwelt of trees
for human understanding,
it underscores the bond between humans
and the wider family of life
through respiration.
As participants follow their outbreath
into a tree, they become one.
Now notice your outbreath again.
Carbon dioxide that leaves your body
lands on a leaf.
Opens its pores to drink it in.
Carbon travels through the phloem
into the branches,
down the tree trunk and even
all the way down to the soil.
Here,
trees are in ancient cooperation
with the kingdom of fungi.
These fine threads of mycelium,
those intelligent, root-like
fungal networks
that nurture and feed an entire ecosystem.
By simply tracing our outbreath,
we realize the reciprocity
between all major kingdoms of life
pulsing with one harmonious rhythm.
This exploration of rich and diverse life
that exists beneath
the surface of the soil
is the next journey we are embarking on.
As fungi capture the public imagination
through groundbreaking research,
we are very much inspired
by the works of Suzanne Simard,
Merlin Sheldrake and many others.
“The Wood Wide Web,”
which is the working title,
will bring us into the primordial
relationship between trees, plants,
animals and fungi,
and aim to dismantle the myth
of human separation
from the natural world.
As an artist collective,
we seek to find emotional resonance
in scientific stories,
stories that connect us
to the more-than-human world
and, coupled with emerging technologies,
deepen our understanding of what is it
to be something other than human.
Modern science is revealing
something Indigenous knowledge
has always held to be true.
That what is outside of us
is not separate from us.
We need this ancient wisdom
more than ever today
and it compels us to use
our technology to both honor
and enhance our relationship
with the web of beings.
The ability to perceive the world
through the eyes and ears of other beings,
through the phloem and xylem of trees,
even reconnects us,
humans, to the fantastic
and richly diverse network of organisms
that make up our shared Earth.
It gives us a greater appreciation
of what is it to be non-human,
which in turn lets us more fully grasp
what is it to be human, too.
And it reminds us with awe
that we are all but extensions
of one another,
from tree to tree, to you and me.
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)